من جديد حاله من الذعر والخوف تنتاب
المدنيين في السودان على وقع زخات الرصاص
والمعارك الكثيفه التي حاصرت مساكنهم رغم
هدنه هشه كسابقتها ما دفع الالاف لجمع
امتعتهم والمصارعه بالفرار تجنبا لنيران
قوات الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
حاله الذعر لم تقتصر على المواطنين
السودانيين فقط بل امتدت الى الاجانب
والبعثات الدبلوماسيه التي بادرت بعمليه
تنظيم رعاياها تمهيدا لنقلهم خارج السودان
بعدما بدات بالفعل دول مثل المانيا
واليابان خططا لاجلاء مواطنيها لكن من
المؤكد ان الاضرابات المستمره واغلاق
المطارات الرئيسيه ستعيق تلك الخطط مصادر
مطلع افادت بان مهمه الجيش الالماني
لاجلاء نحو 150 المانيه من السودان ارجات
بسبب القتال الدائر في العاصمه الخرطوم
وعدم التزام الطرفي الصراع بالهدنه
الثانيه التي تنتهي مساء اليوم كذلك تحدثت
اليابان عن وجود حوالي 60 مواطنا يابانيا
بينهم موظفون في السفاره بالخرطوم فمع
استمرار اغلاق المطارات تعتبر الامم
المتحده ان خطه الاخلاء الفوري جوا
مستحيلا ما دعا الى النظر في امكانيه
استخدام البريه رغم المخاطر الكارثيه التي
تحيط بها
حصيله قتل المواجهات متضاربه لكنها تجاوزت
مئات القتلى والاف الجرحى وهي تبقى مرشحه
للارتفاع مع استمرار الصراع بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع في قلب العاصمه
الخرطوم ومناطق اخرى من البلاد
ازمه تركت اثارها على الجوانب المعيشيه
للمواطنين وضاعفت اسعار المواد الغذائيه
حتى المرافق الصحيه لم تسلم كذلك من تبعات
الصراع حيث اجبرت المستشفيات المرضى على
مغادرتها لنقص امكانيات العلاج والاقامه
ومع استمرار الاشتباكات اصبح من الواضح
انه لا يوجد مكان امن في السودان لحياه
المدنيين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات